[Musique]
helios neuf on n'a jamais pris un seul
cours de piano elle ne sait pas lire les
notes
[Musique]
ce niveau là
nécessite dix ans d'apprentissage
[Musique]
non
super bravo llose hélios un don il lui
suffit d'écouter une musique deux ou
trois fois pour la rejouer sans fausse
note
[Musique]
ça c'est ma gauche comme à droite un
attaquant depuis peu grâce à ce logiciel
il retient toute la mélodie encore plus
vite
j'ai mémoire extraordinaire c'est tout
et une mémoire et qui me dit que je dois
faire et là quand je vois des hommes
je vois les touches qu'ils en pensent
que ce soit mis en rayon ou je ne sais
quoi je la reproduis obtient hélios est
atteint du syndrome d'asperger a appelé
autisme de haut niveau il n'a pas de
déficience intellectuelle mais des
comportements obsessionnels
il avait à peu près trois ans et on
mettait des chansons pour enfants comme
n'importe qui et puis d'un seul coup il
s'est précipité sur le piano et la
rejouer à vous dirais-je maman qui
venait d'entendre et mais s'en foutent
rien et on est resté complètement ahurie
[Musique]
depuis tout petit sa maman a filmé les
exploits de son garçon
[Musique]
e
aceto nocturnes de chopin il a juste
écouter le morceau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hélios est élevé par sa mère aidée par
ses grands parents
leur unique petit fils est autiste ils
sont très fiers de lui nous a dit que
c'était parce que gerland le fait qu'il
était aussi ce que c'est en parlant des
latitudes particulière de déjà il serait
grand de mémoire et puis lisandro et
certains domaines lui ça ira de même sur
la musique elle est aussi celui-là
ah oui mais tu es là pour un cdd je dis
mais pas ce que je sais quoi
l'ordinateur vivre au quotidien avec un
autiste asperger est une épreuve
helios refuse la réalité il vit sur une
autre planète celle de ces histoires
imaginaires ils ont noirci tous ces
cahiers une souffrance pour sa maman
alors pour se rapprocher de lui elle
essaie comme elle peut de pénétrer son
univers peuplé de personnages étranges
et de vélos magic est un lieu magique
mais comment y ressemble à un train non
bah oui il peut changer de forme avec
quoi ils fonctionnent et bah en fait
dans le gasoil
il ya de l'électricité et qui rebondit
partout il est poussé par le ventilateur
et ça va dans la machine
vous voulez un jour je vais vous le
présenter or il au magic
quand on parle avec lui on prend
pratiquement que de ces histoires quand
on essaie de parler avec lui la vie
active fardeau de parler commis par un
enfant de son âge a tout de suite ils
ramènent à ses histoires et ça part en
vrille
je préfère parler d'autre chose ces
histoires c'est bien cinq minutes mais
bon après 5 heures plus étonnant la
manière dont l'enfant justifie son
comportement
la réalité je trouve que série des plus
beaux records parce que j'aime pas être
dans la réalité je ne sers à rien dans
la réalité
moi c'est ce que je trouve et dont les
histoires tu sers à quelque chose oui à
aller très vite
ce que je sais courir en faisant sauter
la route lorsqu hélios est dans son
monde c'est très dur de le faire revenir
sur terre
[Musique]
on va faire un petit tour et les os
allô allô oui il ya quelqu'un lui faire
accomplir les gestes du quotidien comme
se laver manger se coucher ou sortir
s'aérer sont souvent un combat tiens si
on commença donc faut sortir et ou non
au bout d'une demi heure helios daigne
enfin mettre son manteau et ses
chaussures lui mais on fait un petit
tour de ville
en fait le tour du lac ça va diminuer là
il fait ce qu'il veut quand il veut
comme une l'obéissance est vraiment pas
ça dans son univers
la notion de contrainte n'existe pas ça
promet pas un petit lac en banlieue
parisienne leur promenade habituelle ce
qui devrait être un moment de détente et
pour stéphanie une attention de tous les
instants et il n'a pas encore tout à
fait la notion de tous les dangers donc
on faire attention
[Musique]
ma plus de vie personnelle coiffer fois
je consacre tout à hélios c'est plus de
temps pour moi c'est plus d'amis mais
jamais on n'avait pas beaucoup mais je
me vois mon plus c'est vraiment 100%
rieuse et pourquoi
ben parce que ce n'est pas le choix
un petit garçon inadaptée la réalité
mais avec des capacités hors du commun
sur cette vidéo
hélios à deux ans alors qu'à cet âge les
enfants ne prononce que quelques mots
helios lui va réciter tout le livre de
boucle d'or que sa maman lui a lu
seulement deux fois oui exactement
alors elles feront les gros lot et
garonne
incroyable douze pages réciter par coeur
à la dire qu'il prenne une mémoire
exceptionnelle mais hélios et un autre
dont le calcul mental
à 9 ans il est très en avance pour son
âge 85 tirs joue encore deux fois aux
lola 945 par 5 5 x 5 25 je retiens deux
fois 4 22 22 1225 les habitudes de l'ua
plus vifs ont fermé quatre ans par trois
mois sans 4 372 scassa affolant c'est x
veut ébats 302 du bar 2
[Musique]
744 comme lui la plupart d autiste
asperger ronde et faculté étonnante en
mathématiques
certains deviennent ingénieur
informaticien de haut niveau aux joueurs
d'échecs
mais avant tout ils doivent passer par
la case école et chaque matin il y aussi
va à reculons
il aime pas à prendre donc voilà je sais
déjà votre chaussée pour chat commet
attentats pas la science infuse et le
cies faut apprendre pour apprendre un
métier pour bollaert où se produit donc
moi je
un prétexte pour ne pas avouer son mal
être
[Musique]
je pense qu'il vient pas trop l'école
chose qui a beaucoup d'enfants axa
l'angoissant peut aussi l'école une
souffrance pour hélios
mais pour sa maman c'est essentiel bonne
journée mon coeur elle s'est battue pour
qu'ils suivent depuis tout petit une
scolarité normale s'il était avec des
enfants comme lui sera plutôt tirés vers
le bas
donc là pour pour essayer d'être comme
les autres et de s'intégrer qu'il fasse
un effort pour essayer de s'adapter aux
enfants sont très importants conduits
pour justement le pack sans tuer sa
différence
savostine allez en route gravité du
handicap manque de moyen en france 80%
des enfants autistes ne sont pas
scolarisés
helios lui fait partie des chanceux qui
est aujourd'hui en classe de cm1 comme
tous les enfants de son âge pourra
s'attaquer à une autre fonction au saut
d par exemple sauf keylios bénéficie
d'une auxiliaire de vie scolaire payés
par l'éducation nationale qu'il
accompagne chaque jour dans son
apprentissage
[Musique]
de quoi il devra beaucoup travailler
parce que j'ai dépensé
voilà l'été par séquences il ya un cadre
est quand même et puis bien faire les
choses qui ne fait pas en fait il a
écrit sans cette aide
difficile pour reuse d'avoir le niveau
nécessaire en classe de cm1 mais dès
qu'il s'agit de faire des maths a besoin
de prier hélios il a trois en avance sur
ses petits camarades
un enfant précoce mais un enfant
différent lorsque le petit garçon
recentre ou de pression il peut aller
s'exprimer sur ce tableau qui lui
réservait il dessine alors ces fonds ne
histoire qui peuplent son imaginaire
il faut laisser à ineos aucune soupape
c'est à dire que là il a été il ya une
beaucoup de contraintes ce matin et il a
il a besoin de temps en temps de
s'échapper donc là c'est vraiment des
moments que je lui laisse y va un peu
dans son monde et faire ces choses pour
lui laisser le temps de se ressourcer
pour pouvoir le rappeler plus tard à
faire un truc scolaire la récréation du
matin est une épreuve correios accroché
à ce poteau ils hésitent à se jeter à
l'eau à aller vers les autres
hélios a peu d'amis il est souvent seul
dans la cour
mais les enfants de sa classe accepte sa
singularité
[Musique]
il ya beaucoup d'imagination durant max
alier très fort enfin en france un peu
moins gentil la baisse à chaque mercredi
le petit prodige se rend à son cours de
musicothérapie
bonjour hélios ça va on y va en
apparence une leçon de piano qui
commence souvent par un jeu phare mes
yeux la wii la musicothérapeute
utilisent cet instrument pour le faire
parler
[Musique]
ah ça c'est d'accord que je fais souvent
de vrais d'eau veux me des morts est
bien supérieur à d'accord ok
[Musique]
ce jour là helios va lui faire une
révélation étonnante
j'ai l'impression d'être enfin faire
grève on pas en train de danse
j'ai dormi dans huit ans presque 9 et 12
et ne révèle jamais le club de porto
force mais il va s'ouvrir heureux on ne
veut pas tout comme les autres un petit
bourg je me réveille sous l'impression
de vivre à neuilly je sais pas mais ma
musique pour soi et mais où la musique
oui elle est dans la réalité ou alors
elle est dans ton monde alors ça c'est
l'intronisent entre les deux une soirée
exceptionnelle s'annonce pour hélios
dans une heure il va se produire sur
scène
le petit garçon a hâte d'y être
ça me fait plaisir mais ça ne doit pas
j'ai pas l'habitude de faire sourire
moi ce que je retrouve le sourire
oui bien sûr de plus notre souhait
énoncé qu'il soit heureux ce qu'ils
soient heureux dans piano ou pour faire
autre chose ça n'a pas d'importance
nombreux biens quinte ou au piano
ça lui fait plus de bien que quand il
fera ce soir
le petit garçon est l'invité de marque
d'une soirée musicale dans un château
d'accord il va jouer devant une centaine
de personnes
helios ne peut mettre des mots sur ses
émotions
mais stéphanie lit sur son visage une
certaine inquiétude à quelques minutes
du concert
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
un petit garçon hyper sensible qui garde
pour lui son mystère mais grâce au piano
helios dévoile une partie de son âme et
conquiert le public
[Musique]
il ose même jouer ses propres
compositions
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
plus tard helios espère devenir pianiste
aux scénaristes de science fiction pour
se réfugier dans les deux seuls domaines
où il se sent être quelqu'un